können wir mit hilfe von tieren schon
bald in die zukunft sehen elefanten die
tsunamis weit im voraus spüren kröten
die sich retten lange bevor die erde
bebt und ziegen die einen vulkanausbruch
voraussagen können tiere reagieren
äußerst sensibel auf umweltveränderungen
und waren damit vor gefahren und
bedrohungen das internationale
forschungsprojekt chaos macht sich das
zunutze dabei werden tiere als richtige
detektive eingesetzt und das sehr
erfolgreich klicks und feature gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ja nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden dem
technologie magazin des emmett dem
massachusetts institute of technology
und am ende gibt es ein exemplar für
euch kostenlos oder wer ganz ungeduldig
ist jetzt schon unter oder in der video
beschreibung sie sind wirklich überall
unterwegs in den trockensten wüsten dem
tiefsten regenwald und auf den höchsten
bergen tiere die die umwelt erkunden und
genau das machen sich forschungsteams
weltweit bereits heutzutage zunutze die
amerikanische wetter und meereskunde
behörde beispielsweise nur see elefanten
bereits seit einigen jahren als mobile
messbojen sensoren werden an den tieren
befestigt und da diese bis zu 1500 meter
tief tauchen kommen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
so sehr einfach an spannende daten wie
salzgehalt strömung und temperatur der
meere
der große vorteil die damit verbundenen
kosten sind deutlich niedriger als
beispielsweise der einsatz von
tauchrobotern weitere beispiele für
tiere die als messstation fungieren gibt
es viele schnee geyer liefern spannende
daten aus dem himalaya und das aus einer
höhe von mehr als 8000 metern vor allem
in regionen wo wir menschen nur schwer
hingelangen oder wo sich der einsatz von
konventionellen messgeräten kompliziert
gestaltet sind es tiere die die werte
erheben so unter anderem auch auf der le
seite von gebirgen wo oft wolken die
messung per satellit unmöglich machen
gemeint ist hiermit die
einige seite von gebirgen die dem wind
abgewandt ist manchmal ist auch vom
sogenannten sechs in der tiere die rede
so auch kurz vor der
jahrhundertkatastrophe ende des jahres
2004 als ein gewaltiger tsunami im
indischen ozean rund 230.000
menschenleben forderte
medienberichten zufolge hatten sich
tiere dieser gegend im vorfeld äußerst
unruhig verhalten so hatten sich
beispielsweise die elefanten nervös hin
und her bewegt ihre ohren ausgebreitet
und waren einen berg hinauf gerannt auch
die vögel stiegen demnach verschreckte
in den himmel und flogen landeinwärts in
china wurde über ein ähnliches beispiel
berichtet kurz vor einem erdbeben sollen
tausende von kröten bild über die
straßen geübt sein
später starben dann mehr als 50.000
menschen hatten die tiere die drohende
gefahr gewittert oder war es reiner
zufall
klar jedenfalls ist dass tiere mehrere
sinne gleichzeitig einsetzen und somit
in der lage sind kleine veränderungen
sehr viel früher wahrzunehmen als wir
menschen dagegen steht die
ahnungslosigkeit von seismologen die
erst wenige sekunden vor einem erdbeben
wissen dass es so weit ist bislang kann
man einfach nicht voraussagen wann und
wo sich die spannungen an den erdplatten
entladen werden
zwar gibt es beispielsweise in
mexiko-stadt effizienter waren systeme
um die menschen zu alarmieren mit ganz
vielen sensoren
doch das ist eher die ausnahme die
herausforderung liegt darin dass die
hochsensiblen sensoren gut überlegt
platziert werden müssen ähnliche
probleme haben forschungsteams weltweit
bei der vorhersage von vulkanausbrüchen
zwar wurden einige prozesse
identifiziert die einen vulkanausbruch
ankündigen doch der konkrete zeitpunkt
für den ausbruch und auch seine stärke
dass es viel zu komplex um es im vorfeld
physikalisch zu berechnen
auch hier sind uns einige tierarten wie
beispielsweise ziegen und roten
waldameisen voraus der deutsche biologe
martin wikelski vom max planck institut
für ornithologie hat erforscht dass
ziegen vor einem ausbruch des vulkans
ätna außergewöhnlich aktiv wurden und
dass mehrere stunden bevor der vulkan
tatsächlich ausbrach schon vor jahren
hat er sein forschungsteam die ziegen
und schafe vor ort mit tags versehen und
tatsächlich bei den vergangenen sieben
ausbrüchen des etwas hatten die tiere
bereits vier bis sechs stunden vor der
katastrophe
das war
gesucht also zu einem zeitpunkt wo noch
kein anderes messgerät angeschlagen
hatte rote waldameise reagieren
offensichtlich auf ein anstehendes
erdbeben wie forschungsteams aus
duisburg und dortmund berichten die
fachleute hatten über drei jahre hinweg
beobachten sind dass die ameisen sehr
empfindlich auf aktivitäten unter der
erde reagierten durch ihre speziellen
sinnesorgane sind die ameisen
möglicherweise in der lage aufsteigende
gase und vielleicht sogar auch
elektrische spannung wahrzunehmen
diese fähigkeiten der tiere von
fachleute weltweit nutzen um in die
zukunft zu sehen und möglicher
umweltgefahren vorauszusagen sowie die
bergleute etwa ab dem jahr 1880 auch den
harzer roller einen gelben kanarienvogel
für ihre zwecke nutzen denn dieser vogel
singt sogar dann wenn es dunkel ist so
also auch in der grube
doch das tier ist sehr anfällig für
schlechte luft es verstummt sobald die
kohlenmonoxid werte steigen und bereits
nach kurzer zeit wird der vorher
bewusstlos sobald der harzer roller also
in seinem käfig von der stange gibt war
dies den bergleuten eine ernste warnung
vor gefährlichen gasen in der grube die
sie dann schnellstmöglich verließen
doch anders als noch vor 140 jahren
läuft das heute weitaus professioneller
möglich wird das unter anderem auch
durch die miniaturisierung der technik
so dass fachleute den tieren immer
kleinere und komplexere tags mit auf den
weg geben können computer chips also mit
sendern und sensoren ganz vorne mit
dabei das internationale projekt namens
ikarus wobei tiere schon in naher
zukunft die ganze erde vermessen können
ikarus steht für international
cooperation for animal research using
space und wird vom max planck institut
für ornithologie in radolfzell geleitet
mit dabei unter anderem aber auch das
deutsche zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt
dlr und die russische raumfahrtbehörde
roskosmos die empfangsstation wurde im
vergangenen jahr 2019 auf der
raumstation iss montiert tiere auf der
ganzen welt könnten in zukunft also mit
peilsendern und sensoren für temperatur
bewegung und luftdruck ausgestattet
werden und so diese daten regelmäßig und
automatisch an die iss funken wir werden
die funksignale 100 ex gleichzeitig in
hoher auflösung verarbeitet und an die
bodenstationen weiter
leitet so wird die datenerhebung
deutlich einfacher gemacht als bei
regionalen und bodengebundenen
empfängern die fachleute können somit
nicht nur die umweltdaten aus extrem
entlegenen regionen der erde gewinnen
sondern auch - verfolgen was die tiere
gerade machen wann schlafen sie wann und
wo fressen sie auf welchen routen
bewegen sie sich und wann und warum
sterben sieht dazu der wissenschaftler
martin wikelski der maßgeblich am
großprojekt beteiligt ist so gewinnen
wir nicht nur viel tiefere einblicke wie
tiere auf umweltveränderungen reagieren
um den artenschutz zu verbessern
wir werden auch auf umweltgefahren
aufmerksam die sonst länger unbemerkt
geblieben werden ist es möglicherweise
vor allem das schwarmverhalten der tiere
dass sie so intelligent macht ist es
also eine kollektive intelligenz quasi
eine art algorithmus im verhalten der
tiere der ihnen das überleben sichert
doch wie genau stehen dabei die
interaktion der tiere und ihr verhalten
in der gruppe in zusammenhang mit diesem
sechsten sinn ein erster test im rahmen
des ikarus projekts bezieht sich auf den
zug der amseln somit soll endlich eine
spannende und bislang ungeklärte
forschungsfrage geklärt werden warum
zieht nur die hälfte der amsel
populationen in mitteleuropa und
nordamerika über den winter nach süden
und warum bleibt die andere hälfte vor
ort in stuttgart und karlsruhe sollen
tauben eingesetzt werden um daten zur
luft chemie zu sammeln doch als
bioindikatoren umfasst der
einsatzbereich der tiere noch viel mehr
denn mit ihrer hilfe könnten sogar
verbrechen aufgeklärt werden
beispielsweise könnte der illegalen
fischfang eingedämmt und wilderern das
handwerk gelegt werden das problem bei
der illegalen fischerei die fischtrawler
schalten während ihrer machenschaften
die transponder der automatischen
identifizierungssystem ab und so werden
die elegant fischer unsichtbar für die
satellitenüberwachung nicht jedoch für
die albatrosse die noch aus 30
kilometern entfernung jedem fischtrawler
aufspüren und auf leichte beute hoffen
wenn die tiere mit einem
solarbetriebenen peilsender ausgestattet
werden verraten sie somit über das
radiosignal des schiffes auch die
illegalen fischer die troller lassen
ihrer dann nämlich weiterlaufen da sie
sonst nicht mehr in der lage sind zu
navi
ein französisches forschungsteam konnte
so mit hilfe von knapp 180 albatrossen
das riesige ausmaß der illegalen
fischerei im südlichen indischen ozean
offenbar in einem gebiet das viermal so
groß wie europa ist registrierten die
vögel 353 schiffe doch der abgleich mit
dem vorgeschriebenen automatischen
erkennungssystem zeigte dass 100 davon
der offiziellen überwachung entgehen
wollten in afrika zeigt ein anderes
projekt eindrucksvoll wie tiere
verbrechen aufspüren können ganz konkret
werden hier illegale wilderei adapter
zum martin wikelski anfangs hatten wir
die idee nashörner oder löwen direkt zu
tekken anhand ihrer bewegungsmuster
können wir eindeutig erkennen wenn sie
gejagt und geschossen werden schicken
wir dann die ranger los ist es aber
meist zu spät
und genau deswegen stehen jetzt tiere
wie gazellen giraffen und zebras im
visier des forschungsteams denn diese
flucht tiere zeigen ganz bestimmte zitat
herden flucht muster wenn ihnen bilder
rational kommen und genau diese muster
sind viel eindeutiger von anderen
gefahren zu unterscheiden nun erarbeiten
die forschungen ein alarmsystem wobei
giraffen zebras und gazellen mit
solarbetriebenen ohrmarken text
ausgestattet werden doch es sind nicht
nur säugetiere die als frühwarnsystem
fungieren könnten sondern auch insekten
oder kleine vögel
möglich wird das weil sender und
sensoren dank neuer technologien in
zukunft noch kleiner werden derzeit sind
die leichtesten davon 3,8 gramm schwer
wenn sie personal kraft betrieben werden
und 2,3 gramm schwer
wenn sie mit batterien laufen derzeit
sind die kleinsten vögel die eine solche
last tragen können etwa so groß wie 100
gramm schwerer kuckuck doch die pläne
der fachleute sind groß dazu martin
wikelski in einem konsortium mit
mehreren instituten und unternehmen
arbeiten wird daran unter ein gramm zu
kommen dann können wir auch kleinere
vögel und sogar insekten bei sendern die
uns noch viel mehr über die
zusammenhänge in der natur verrat
langfristig gesehen soll so ein
sensorsystem entstehen das die gesamte
erde umspannt möglich machen könnte das
ein netzwerk an satelliten die den
tieren nach horch und das könnte dann
nicht nur uns menschen zugute kommen
sondern auch den tieren selbst dazu
stefan dech vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt wenn wir anhand der
von ihnen
lieferten daten geschichten vom
schicksal gefährdeter tierarten erzählen
können entsteht in der bereitschaft
wirklich etwas für den umwelt- und
artenschutz zu tun ja spannende
zukunftsperspektiven sind das und noch
mehr davon gibt es bei technology review
hier wird in jeder ausgabe in die
zukunft geschaut in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion von technology review ist
dieses video entstanden und exklusiv für
pixum zuschauende gibt es jetzt eine
ausgabe gratis kriegt dafür einfach da
auf den link oder unten in die video
beschreibung und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran